خمسة آلاف هكتار أكثر من اثني عشر
ألف ملعب كرة قدم احترقت في
ليلة واحدة ، حيث وصلت
درجات الحرارة داخل منطقة النار في
هذا المجتمع في فرنسا المتنامية
إلى ألف درجة مئوية وفقًا
لإدارة الإطفاء المحلية بما يكفي لثني
الفولاذ
، وما زلنا في مرحلة محاولة
احتواء  تتمثل مهمتنا في
توجيهها حيث نريد حيث يوجد
عدد أقل من الغطاء النباتي حيث يسمح التصميم
لمركباتنا بوضع نفسها بشكل أفضل
بأكثر الطرق فعالية
، حيث تتسبب درجات الحرارة الحارقة وشهور من الطقس الجاف في
حدوث ظروف خطيرة في
جميع أنحاء أوروبا والقارة في
وسطها
غرد رئيس الاتحاد الأوروبي أورسولا فونديرلان
يوم الجمعة بأن المساعدة كانت واردة إلى
البرتغال سلوفينيا وألبانيا وفرنسا
كجزء من آلية الحماية المدنية للكتلة
بعد نداء طارئ من باريس
يوم الخميس ، أرسل الاتحاد الأوروبي أربع
طائرات إطفاء إلى فرانسيس جنوب غرب البلاد.
كافحت الخدمات
حرائق الغابات لستة متتالية
بدأت التعزيزات الليلية من رومانيا في
الوصول صباح يوم الجمعة ، لا
يهم البلد نحن
رجال إطفاء وعلينا مساعدة الناس
في
جميع أنحاء العالم
في المملكة المتحدة ، تظل فرقة الإطفاء في لندن
في حالة تأهب قصوى وتصف
المدينة بأنها شركات المياه الجافة Tinder box
أدخلت فرقًا
نظرًا لظروف الجفاف التي تمنع
الناس من سقي حدائقهم
بغسل السيارات أو تنظيف النوافذ
حتى جف نهر تيم في
اتجاه مجرى النهر أكثر من أي وقت مضى ، هذه هي
أزمة المناخ في العمل التي وقفت
فيها حول عمق التايمز على
بعد 15 كيلومترًا  يجب أن أكون
أكثر رطوبة مما أنا عليه الآن ،
كان نهر الراين في ألمانيا
منخفضًا بشكل استثنائي يهدد بمزيد من
الاضطراب في أهم
مجرى مائي داخلي في ألمانيا
يستخدم لنقل المواد الكيميائية في الحبوب ،
يعتبر نهر الراين ضروريًا بشكل
خاص لحركة الفحم الذي
يزداد الطلب عليه  بينما ترفع ألمانيا لملء
مرافق التخزين قبل الشتاء المقبل
يقول خبراء الأرصاد ج  ترتبط الموجة الحالية من
درجات الحرارة القصوى التي تجتاح
أوروبا بقبة قوية من
الضغط الجوي المرتفع ليس فقط لأن هذه
القبة تجلب الهواء الساخن إلى المنطقة
بل إنها تمنع العواصف والسحب التي
تحبس الحرارة وتمنعها من
الارتفاع
ويقول العلماء إن كل موجة حر في
العالم  أصبحت التجارب اليوم
أكثر سخونة بسبب تغير المناخ الذي يسببه الإنسان في
بعض مناطق عزيز سي إن إن لندن